à chaque pause de l'émission benjamin
castaldi appelle sa femme pour lui
demander s'il est bien à l'antenne
non c'est pas vrai si si c'est non non
je tapais rappelle à chaque pot c'est
vrai ça va si vous êtes bien mais la
vérité ne manquez pas votre pas me
demandez moi moi pendant là
justement j'ai vite d'avoir votre
regardons être parfois je demande si ça
si ça va c'est ça va encore c'est vrai
quoi vous dire que j'ai pas un million
ça ça dépend des fois des poids lourds
ont été mauvais il n'est pas militaire
en tout cas sans fenêtre merci et bravo
on mettra la
main parce qu'ils voient pas du tout
quand on lui ment
le gros dossier bon allez on le regrette
et je suis d'accord
d'accord
non la semaine prochaine c'est chaud
patate
après c'est ici
j'ai ici
le nom de la prochaine nouvelle star
la tête et steeve estatof
deux
chroniqueurs je dis bien chroniqueur
chronique des âmes donc 2 ha non un
homme
et une femme lors d'un bal je vais vous
dire s'il vous plaît dans ce calme leurs
graffs souplet deux chroniqueurs aurait
eu une aventure
lors d'un déplacement
avec les ics je sais je vous donnais
juste je vais juste vous donner un
indice
parmi les chroniqueurs
sus concerné
1,2
à les petits vieux une grosse poitrine
temps attends attends bas problème n'est
pas le pays au voyage c'est là le
problème et
je dis bien qu' à forniquer non arrêté à
[ __ ] et aux trousses du chemin
comprenez écoutez j'ai dit que la
personne avait des petits dieux et des
gros ça veut pas dire que ses parents
même si c'est vrai que la déception
il est encore temps de recul et cyril je
ne recule jamais vous allez brisé une
famille
brisé une famille jabri serait plus pour
lui ce sera pas la première fois
quelque chose de concorde je vais vous
dire
je les ai à [ __ ] cette terrible
malheur à castaldi vous serez toujours
le bienvenue à la maison
je vous demande juste un truc quand vous
prenez votre douche et un soutien
benjamin castadi envoie vahirua il ya
une rumeur oui
et sur cette rumeur elle vient de vous
on m'a dit que l'équipe m'a dit que ça
venait de vous mais en fait d'un bénin
il est enfin oui il est fou comme je le
faisais je vais beaucoup moto poucave il
se vante vous qu'avez-vous pour kamel
ben jamin castaldi est ce vrai alors je
vous le dis ça n'a pas du tout forniquer
mais a il ya eu un bisou non
c'est que cette histoire est finie
c'est en laye l'autre kg pour dire
ce que c'est parce que ces bailleurs
défense alors je vous raconte tout nous
sommes dans l'est alors s'il te plaît et
et surtout non non non non non benjamin
castaldi choquant même pour l'instant
tant sur avale sa salive
tu es sûr bazin avait cassé dit que tu
veux raconter ça bah oui bien sûr mais
tu es sur wii est ce que tu veut
peut-être enlever ton slip
oui un homme et benjamin castaldi avec
une fleur de toi je le rappelle parfois
je veux dire moi de ce que je vais dire
ce que fais tu va nous dire ah rétine qu
en laponie
en laponie fait très froid
et benjamin castaldi
avait comme tout le monde à petit un
mister freeze dans le slip
delphine j'adore une amie était avec
nous en laponie à nous a rejoint elle
nous a rejoint exactement j'avais oublié
on était bien de le dire un indice
delphine je vous racontais en laponie
kelly vdev n'y étais loin a été dans une
chambre dans une tour dans un tour
d'ivoire elle ne voyait personne et
cette chance a laissé cette chance si on
a eu la chance aussi d'avoir loin
il y avait ma chambre grand champ très
belle à l'eau ne bout pas dire on va
dire à palerme
sicile avait ma chambre avec des pétales
sur l'a8 ailleurs j'aime raconter c'est
une catastrophe j'ai eu des pactoles
l'audio
[Applaudissements]
à chaque fois à chaque fois que
j'arrivais le tu as l'air quelques
palmiers l'hérault c'est pourquoi
j'ai mis des pétales de rose partout
dans ma chambre c'est un enfer pour
dormir je me les réveiller avec des
pétales patois c'est insupportable en
tout cas je sentais très très bon
et en face de ma chambre
il n'y avait la chambre de delphine
wespiser mais vraiment on était face à
face donc je savais tout ce qui se
passait dans la chambre d'en face c'est
entre qui sort et j'ai entendu un moment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il
benjamin castaldi
est au coeur de toutes les invectives
et jusqu aux besoins castaldi
est soupçonné
d'avoir eu
une aventure avec gatineau
en laponie
laponie la peau nos d'après noces
si j'étais toi je me ferais tout
ça shake dat hinzpeter essayé de
m'appeler ya un instant je viendrai à la
la je pense donc delphine wespiser et en
flip
delphine wespiser veux juste savoir
peut-être la vérité je vous la donne et
2,7 les deux versions du bien la fox
news j'y vais alors petite heure gros
seins
je vous rappelle je rappelle que vous
étiez en laponie ciridd bien sûr il n
est que votre jeu préféré en laponie de
bouleverser les règles et de faire
notamment le jeu des chambres
et vous avez décidé de tirer au sort les
champs pour que chacun dorment avec les
uns et les autres voilà en plus j'avais
une chambre de merde je vous le dis
c'était la plus petite avec un tout
petit écran comme ça vous l'avez vu
petit mais les tpe
dont le tirage au sort il se trouve que
ce qui devait dormir ensemble c'était
castaldi et wespiser mais moi je savais
que derrière cette mise en scène cette
mascarade mais tout ça pour la
télévision c'était pour rigoler pour du
jeu pas du talent tu pas moi je croyais
ne croyez plus ils ne croisent et je
croyais pas mais
tu crois pas que j'étais pour de rire
bon je vais donc me coucher dans mon
petit dans cette petite chambre merdique
calmez vous s'il vous plaît et qui
frappe à ma porte delphine wespiser
aulas s'est elle dit sur la tête des
gosses c'est la vérité
ap
non
parce que les gens veulent savoir les
français doivent savoir mais j'ai fait
le s'il vous plaît pas de panique donc
est ce que je veux dire de dormir avec
toi je dis maintenant tu peux pas dormir
avec moi enfin parce que c'était pour
deux c'était pour de faux c'était pour
rigoler mais moi je veux dormir dans
cette chambre et série qu'il a dit mais
quand c'est les deux choses essentielles
comme ça valait vraiment quand voilà ce
règlement agglo mais ça va dépanner je
veux que cyril puisse faire sa séquence
tranquillement qu il y avait tout un
petit peu ennuyeux quand même parce que
voilà c'est ça une autre version
bref que bref donc j'ai dû expliquer
gentiment il ya bien un canapé si elle
voulait dormir si vous voulez dormir
mamadou diouf rumeurs bouzid negache
vous important quand même le cheval vous
en pensez
donc ce sont mes commentaires
c'est donc oui j'ai dit il c'est donc
couché si on est couché sur ce canapé
quoi qui n'a pas été le lui annoncer mon
lit quand même
commentaire et brême ger bat cédric
goujat elle s'est couchée dans cette
date dans ce cas la paix et woods
académique défi que que fais-tu débat
j'attends mais je dis que tu attends
quoi de voir le loup nos
amis japonais daniel
non mais c'est pas possible
c'est edel tu viennes partie
donc à venise et attend qu'on fasse la
séquence des mes delphine qu'il n'y aura
pas de séquences que tout le monde dort
donc ça sert à rien que tu fais donc je
lui ai gentiment dit que ça ne servait
de coucher dans ma chambre j'ai dû
repartir ailleurs bien volonté donc elle
a eu il obtient absolument rire c'est
alors que j'ai vu et je me manque pas du
tout je vous demande bas du dos à tel
point que cette histoire a chuté un
petit peu et ça m'a mis un petit peu en
colère ma femme a donc expliqué ce qui
s'était passé ben d'accord a expliqué
pat farmer accrue et ma femme m'a cru
parce que ma femme me crois parce que
j'aime beaucoup mais va pas mal est bien
sympa
voilà on est en train de faire ses
[Rires]
camions et bah voila je peux je peux en
revanche et je sais que fort de cet
échec dans ma chambre je sais qu'après
elle a fait le tour d'autres chambres
bien sûr nos producteurs de l'émission
fine au téléphone delphine elle est là
elle est au téléphone alors moi nordine
ce qu'elle a dit delphine aller te
téléphone delphine tu veux réagir
de laponie à strasbourg en passant par
mulhouse bonsoir des sites genève la r6
un peu loin je suis un peu loin pour me
défendre
il est dés coquins fait raccord je suis
pas là en fait alors delphine sache-le
on a préféré faire quand t'étais pas là
mais on fait quand même moi je croyais
que tu étais là plus aujourd'hui
delphine uns et pas les jolies pas non
plus on m'appelle peu un combat nist oui
alors
qu'est ce que j'ai à faire dans cette
affaire
dans leur dessine
pour la cohésion de l'équipe et tous de
faire des roulements de chambre
de faire un vrai défi comme un parti
comme ça c'est l'autre pour des
séquences où les cecos et en os mis un
doigt là où marrante et tout ça et est
donc by ap une impulsion donc moi est la
première chambre que j'ai trouvé ben
j'ai toqué la première chambre qui m'a
ouvert effectivement c'était benjamin du
coup je suis allé j'ai dit bah écoutes
je sais pas s'il veut qu'on fasse un
truc vas-y marché soit amputé d'un
deuxième lit et tout et puis moi ça me
dérange pas de dormir dans la chambre d
autres enfin puisque je ne vois pas le
mal moi je dors dans la ville d'austin
de ventura c'est vrai elle dort très
souvent avec des garçons non mais je
vous jure que non mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai ces maladies enfin y'a pas de
billets pas trop la voile avec mes amis
du coup
oui tout on a un peu parlé c'est un
marathon
et au bout d'un moment
il ne répondait plus et c'est ont envie
comment ça vous plaît
donc il n'y a rien eu rien merci on
verra comme sur 7
[Applaudissements]